these are the photos that may come back
to haunt Laurie Lachlan and her husband
Massimo Jian Ulis the 55 year old
actress filed her motion to dismiss last
month this week the US attorney filed
their response denying the claims in her
motion and here's why prosecutors filed
a lengthy response to Laurie's motion in
which they staunchly deny any
allegations of misconduct and they
included the two photos we first showed
you prosecutors blurred their faces but
say they're Laughlin's daughters Olivia
Jade and Isabella Rose on rowing
machines the federal government's
response is something that we were
waiting for and it was pretty strong I
mean 36 pages here really showing how
what they did wasn't wrong at all they
made some very strong arguments
including introducing new evidence that
Massimo as well as Lori they both knew
what was really going on here
Lachlan and Gia newly are accused of
paying five hundred thousand dollars in
bribes to get the two daughters admitted
to USC as recruits for the crew team
even though neither of them had ever
participated in the sport you don't have
to use the word bribe for it to be a
bribe the government is 100% correct
here and their argument that if you look
at all the conversations that these
people had with singer before a recorded
conversation it seems to demonstrate
that they knew that what they were doing
was engaging in a prize in the latest
court dogs obtained by ET on Wednesday
the US attorney also alleges that gia
newly falsely told a high school
counselor that his daughter was a rower
he knew his daughter wasn't that kind of
athlete and he kept pushing this false
narrative so the defendants own words
are coming back to bite them and that
was clearly illustrated in this document
what's more prosecutors allege that gia
newly actually took the photos in
question and used them to back up his
false claims regarding Olivia and
Isabella's rowing experience but Lori's
lawyers are firing back according to the
motion and subsequent memo supporting
the dismissal motion Laughlin's lawyers
allege that prosecutors acted
inappropriately in regards to one of the
main witnesses bribery scam ringleader
Rick singer and that they try to conceal
exculpatory evidence but in the court
Doc's obtained by ET on Wednesday the
and claims there is no basis for the
dismissal request what the defendants
really wanted to happen here was to have
these recordings between singer and
Julie Ellie and Laughlin thrown out in
other words that a jury would never hear
them that they're tainted they're bad
the government pressured singer and
pressured these defendants into a scheme
that they really weren't a part of while
the government is saying that's not the
case that's not the case at all we've
shown you enough evidence to support
that singer and all these defendants
really knew what was going on and
everybody's just trying to protect
themselves right now and if there's
really an issue about what was going on
then a jury should decide this
well Gian Uli and Laughlin have pleaded
not guilty to all charges leveled
against them they claim their payments
were donations to the school and not
bribes at this point it doesn't look
great for Lori Loughlin and Massimo June
le based upon what we've seen from the
government's filing in the law this is
gonna proceed towards trial I'd be very
surprised if the judge either throughout
this entire indictment and cleared them
or even at the very least made those
secret conversations I don't think
that's gonna happen
meanwhile source tells ET Laurie is
exhausted worrying about the case adding
that at this point she and her husband
have absolutely no plans to make a deal
despite the feds response to her
allegations according to our source the
prosecution's pressure has had no effect
and Laurie and her husband maintain that
they made a charitable donation we're
just a nice normal family you know like
we don't we don't have anything
outrageous really happening on the home
front our source says that everyone is
getting along well I think that Olivia
and Bella have been more at ease since
the family made the case and off-limits
topic at home we've had our moments but
overall I am happy and proud of my girls
according to the source Laurie's
decision to allow the girls back on
social media has also eased a lot of the
tension adding quote they felt as if
they were being blamed and even punished
because of their mother's mistake all
that is in the past and time has helped
to heal looking at their daughter's
reaction to all this and their behavior
at this time it's kind of hard to tell
what's going on it's kind of hard to
tell what the dynamic is within that
family you hear rumors that there's
tension in the family but behind closed
doors who knows what's being said and
what they're
do also it's hard to let any young
person know exactly tell them what they
should do and not do on social media so
at this point there seems to be way to
two completely different things going on
[Music]